I'm Greta I wondered how it felt to be  publicly insulted by the American  president in the US Treasury secretary  what effect does that have on you of  course no effect  we are we are being criticized like that  all the time and of course if we would  care about that then we wouldn't be able  to do what we do we cannot care about  those kinds of things if we are we have  put ourselves in this spotlight and then  we we know that as we said people do not  understand the situation I mean the  situation is not being treated as the  crisis it is and then of course people  will criticize us because we are the  ones who are telling this and it's basic  and no one else is telling this  you